welcome dr. Carson honor to have you
with us thank you I'm delighted to be
here so I watched with rapt attention
the Fox debate the other night and you
had a couple of really good one-liners
you dropped in there a couple a couple
zingers that were pretty good but the
one the one that we won't have today was
a Megan I'm glad you let me talk finally
I don't know if you're gonna get much
airtime there so we won't have that
problem we got 30 minutes here for just
you and I to hang out and talk you know
one of the things that popped into my
head when I was thinking about you
coming by here is there's this huge
groundswell and it's a varying levels of
anger or passion and it's somewhat you
know some of its kind of off the hinge
and some of it's not just this anti
Washington Washington rhetoric and for
sure that's part of your appeal for sure
that's happening and people are just
disgusted and some of them are just
generally disgusted they don't even know
why others have very specific things
that they're just tired of the idiocy
out of there and the fact that you're
not one of those folks is playing well
for you isn't it oh it's playing
extraordinarily well as well it should
be because you know this country was
designed around the people the people
were supposed to be at the pinnacle and
it was supposed to be up for and by the
people with the government there for one
purpose only and that was to facilitate
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness for the people but what we
have observed we the people is that that
whole thing has been turned upside down
now and the government comes along and
it dictates for instance with the
so-called Affordable Care Act government
comes along and says this is what we're
doing it really doesn't matter what you
people think if you don't like it too
bad you know that really is a
fundamental shift in the in the
relationship between the government and
the people and if the people accept that
that's the beginning of a real
fundamental change in America you know
it it's almost we will surrender that
portions of the population will
surrender that proper relationship of
where the boss of you people in
Washington rather than you're the boss
of us like a four-year-old you're not
the boss of me will almost surrender
that if we get what we want out of
Washington it's almost like they they're
trading their freedom for a handout well
it's it's a mentality that has infested
us in recent decades it wasn't always
like that you know in the beginning
first of all we put a great emphasis on
education in this country when the
Tocqueville came to America in 1831 to
study us because the Europeans were
flabbergasted they couldn't understand
how a nation barely fifty years old was
already competing with them on virtually
everything and as he studied you know he
came to understand that we really put
education on the front line anybody
finishing the second grade was
completely literate he could find a
mountain man the guy could read the
newspaper could have an intelligent
conversation could tell him how the
Constitution work only the aristocracy
and Europe could do that but because we
had people who knew how to do things we
were able to move all the way across
this country from one seat to the other
seat across the rugged and hostile
terrain and we had people who knew how
to build roads and structurally sound
bridges and containment facilities and
dams and they know how to invent things
when a problem came up we had the can-do
attitude and the can-do attitude
propelled us from nowhere to the
pinnacle of the world in record time now
we have traded that can-do attitude for
the what can you do for me attitude and
you know in more than 30 states you can
actually make more money by accepting
government subsidies then you can from
working a minimum-wage job and a lot of
people say you know what
why should I work when I can collect
this money doing that now in the old
days they would have made a very
different choice they would have said
I'm going to
take the minimum wage job because I'm
going to learn skills I'm going to meet
people I'm going to have opportunities
to climb the ladder and I'm going to be
much better off than the person getting
the subsidies but that mentality has
taken over and that is one of the things
that we're going to have to change but
you're not going to be able to change it
by declaration the way we change that is
we Stoke up the economic engine once
again this country has the most powerful
economic engine the world has ever seen
but it cannot operate because we have
entwined it with a gazillion regulations
and with a you're talking to a business
yeah and with a tax system that is
absolutely antithetical to
entrepreneurial risk-taking and capital
investment so yeah again you're talking
to a business guide only going to talk
me into that one no let me expand on
that just a second thing because I I was
thinking you know the best news is about
dr. ben Carson is he's not from
Washington from a practical tactical
know what to do when you sit in the
White House you're a first year resident
I mean you don't have a clue how are you
going to handle that because that to me
that would be intimidating where I'm
trying to do what you're trying to do
well you know I certainly know the
principles and I probably know the
Constitution much better than most of
the people in Washington but as a doctor
one of the things that I've learned
particularly we're dealing with very
complex situations is to get a consult
and sometimes you have to get multiple
consults the Bible says in the multitude
of counselors is safety and that was
written by the guy who's supposed to be
the wisest man who ever lived
now if he recognizes that certainly I
think any of us should recognize that as
well so you run yourself with the people
who know the things that you do not know
but I think wisdom and judgment quite
frankly I don't want to and that note no
pun intended but wisdom and judgment
Trump you know just knowledge
and a and in lifetime experience in
politics
oh you're you know I'm sitting in the
presence of a brain surgeon so what is
the difference in wisdom and
intelligence to you
well wisdom is knowing how to utilize
the information effectively versus just
knowledge there are a lot of very
knowledgeable people I say there are a
ton of PhDs who are total fools you know
they can have all this knowledge but
they have no idea what to do with it or
they use it in a very inappropriate way
so you gather consult so something like
um I'm just thinking as a regular guy
because a couple of years ago you did
the speech the famous speech and it
launched you into this limelight and put
you on this journey by the way did you
have any idea any inkling that when you
stood up there and said that stuff that
was going to lead to this no no I did
not I mean I knew God was up to
something
when I was asked to do it because I had
done it in 1997 when President Clinton
was in office and I wasn't aware anyone
ever did it twice and then I found out
that one person did it twice and that
was Billy Graham
and I said Lord what are you up to here
is really good enough that's a big
shears right there so some really big
shoes Wow I didn't really know until the
day of the / breakfast that morning when
I awakened I knew exactly what I was
going to talk about I had no idea it was
going to have the profound effect that
it but it was basically voicing what
millions of people felt and I heard from
so many people particularly elderly
people who said I was just waiting to
die I had given up on America until I
heard you speak wow now I got to meet
your wife a few minutes ago candy and
his candy yes I guess that right you
know so my old my old friend zig Zigler
who passed away a few years ago he used
to say I knew him too he used to say he
came up to me about the third time here
admit me he said Dave out you know I
don't respect a man they can't marry up
and I deeply respect you
no question about it total agreement
from me you I'll put it you outputted
your coverage brother without a doubt
other women in your life that are
influential I've heard you talk about
your mom yes sounds like the kind of
financial homespun wisdom that I use
around here we used to call it common
sense it's highly marketable now I make
a good living off of it but what what
what lessons should somebody that is
going to be a leader in America take
from someone like your mom well you know
my mother was one of 24 children she was
born right here in Tennessee and I know
that Chattanooga really yeah and managed
to get together up to a third-grade
education before she got married at age
13 and they ended up moving to Detroit
and some years later she discovered my
father was a bigamist and she was trying
to raise us all by herself with a
third-grade education but she believed
in hard work and she did not believe in
making excuses and she worked to the
three jobs at a time and in her attempt
to stay off of welfare and the reason
she wanted to stay off of welfare is
because she was observant and she
noticed that when people went on it they
stayed on it they didn't come off of it
and she occasionally accepted some aid
but for the most part she was able to
stay off of it and she she wouldn't
accept excuses from us either and I
think that was product that was them
that was the best thing that she did I
kind of smelled that she might have been
pretty tough as a mom she was very tough
as a mom but you know in a in a
neighborhood where there was a lot of
failure you know she raised her son who
was a brain surgeon and one who was a
rocket scientist so you know I think
that it wasn't a fluke I think if you
took my mother and you put her in almost
any home with kids they would turned out
okay and parental influence is much
greater than a lot of people give it
credit for it's much more important than
the environment and and you know she
made us read books and that was really
the key even though I didn't want to do
it believe me I did not want to read
those books but as I started reading
about people of accomplishment
I began to understand that the person
who has the most to do what happens to
you in life is you and that was the key
the other thing about her is that you
know she saved every penny every nickel
every day she didn't spend anything
unnecessarily and she would drive a car
until it would not make a noise and then
she would go and buy a new car and
neighbors and everybody was always
wonder how was that woman able to buy a
new car
she must be selling her body she must be
doing something but oh she was just
being extraordinarily wise and thrifty
very frugal very frugal that probably is
a good segue into you've put out a tax
plan yes tell us about that well you
know my plan I make no bones about it is
based on the Bible and the concept of
tithing because I think God is pretty
fair guy and he thought it was fair he
didn't say if you have a bumper crop you
owe me triple tithe and if you crave
your crops fail you don't owe me
anything so there's something something
fear about proportionality you make 10
billion dollars a year you pay a billion
you make ten dollars a year you pay one
you have the same rights and privileges
I don't know anything could be more fair
than that particularly if you get rid of
all the deductions and all the loopholes
now there are a lot of people who say
it's not fair because the guy who put in
a billion he still got nine billion left
and that's not fair we need to take more
of his money
well of course that's called socialism
and those systems never work over the
long run what really propelled America
to the pinnacle and record time was we
took just the opposite tact we said that
guy put in a billion dollars let's make
the environment even friendlier so that
next year he can make twenty billion and
put two billion dollars in that's what
propelled America to the pinnacle of the
world we declared our independence in
1776 less than a hundred years later
with the economic power of the world a
position that we maintained incidentally
until last year when China took over my
pastors are not interesting
so a 10% flat tax well it would have to
be somewhere between 1010 and 15% if you
eliminate all the deductions in order to
just maintain where we are now I would
want to get actually in a better
situation than we are now so the other
thing that has to be done is the sides
the government has to be reduced
significantly there's a lot of stuff
that we're doing that doesn't make any
sense we have a Department of Veterans
Affairs we don't need a Department of
Veterans Affairs Veterans Affairs should
be folded in under the Department of
Defense and it should be smooth
transition and we need to be looking at
the way we take care of soldiers you
know 14% down recruitment for our
volunteer army right now why because
they're looking at what we're doing to
our veterans when a person applies for
the military they should be in a support
system immediately from day one
particularly when they go through combat
and because that's when all the trauma
is occurring and we should have people
in place a year before their time of
discharge to be working on their
integration back into society there
shouldn't be a period of unemployment
when they come out of the military and
they should have a health savings
account which allows them to go to any
medical facility in the country and we
should be delighted to take care of them
and we should use the VA facilities for
specialized care for traumatic brain
injury limb replacements and research
how do you get through the morass that
is called Congress to get anything done
up there well the big problem with
Congress right now we've sent a lot of
good people to Congress in the last few
elections and the reason that nothing
has changed is because we don't have
aggressive leadership what it's going to
require I believe and I talked to some
Congress people about this and they
agree with me is strong leadership from
the White House if we get strong
leadership from the White House a lot of
people who are kind of very timid right
now will stand up but if they stand up
right now without strong leadership they
just get smacked back down
interesting so um what do you do with
Obamacare then well we're going to get
rid of it but you can't get rid of it
without having a replacement and the
replacement would be health savings
accounts that work extremely well
everywhere they're utilized and you look
at the people in Singapore how happy
they are they pay a quarter of what we
pay for health care but I would change
it to a health savings account over
which you have complete control like you
have control over your savings account
not one that has six bureaucrats on it
and you pay for it with the same dollars
that we pay for health traditional
health care with except we wouldn't have
to use as many of them and you give
people flexibility so that if you were
five hundred dollars short for a minor
procedure your wife could give it to you
out of hers or your daughter or your
uncle your cousin your grandfather it
makes every family essentially their own
insurance company with no middleman
gives you enormous flexibility to cover
almost anything that comes up and it
also makes every family concerned about
each other if Uncle Joe is smoking like
a chimney everybody's going to be hiding
in cigarettes it's a good thing it also
makes the cost of catastrophic insurance
drop dramatically because the only thing
that's coming out of your catastrophic
policy it's real catastrophic event how
often do they occur not very often just
like having a homeowner's policy with a
big deductible versus a homeowner's
policy where you want every scratch
cover two very different animals and if
you allow it to be bought across state
lines introduced you know that free
market aspect you're going to drive the
cost down even further it makes it very
affordable for three-quarters of the
people not so much for the indigent what
do you do for them well we have we take
care of them now with Medicaid four to
five hundred billion dollars annual
Medicaid budget how many of you know
she saw that I would say thank you for
coming that's knowledge on I know you've
got another appointment this is more
important but thank you absolutely I can
sit and talk to you all day let's have
you sir all right thank you thank you
very much athletes dr. ben Carson
[Music]